prenons à présent la direction de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une conférence
débat sur la thématique et libertés
sécurité étaient organisées dans un
amphithéâtre de la faculté de droit et
de sciences politiques à lyon court
michel tubiana président d'honneur de la
ligue des droits de l'homme étaient
présents à cette occasion pour débattre
pendant plus de deux heures avec une
vingtaine et des types d'étudiants
il était temps au micro de notre
journaliste et metella et demi d'euros
après chaque grand événement comme les
attentats de new york comme les
attentats de paris
un peu plus de mesure de contrôler un
peu qu une mesure drastique un peu moins
de liberté au prétexte nous disons nous
dit-on d'une amélioration de la sécurité
ou pour garantir notre sécurité
lorsque je constate et chacun peut le
constater c'est que les lois s'empilent
les mesures restrictives de liberté sans
piles et en même temps la sécurité n'est
pas systématiquement là